it's obviously a great pleasure to be
able to introduce ambassador saw de vive
here at Yale in many ways the ambassador
is his personal life or his professional
life exemplifies the history of his
country he started out as a man of high
culture in the Soviet Union highly
educated with degrees in Leningrad and
in the Central Committee of the
Communist Party Institute he's got a PhD
in philosophy from Kazakhstan University
as well as a PhD in political science
from Moscow State University which is
both remarkably impressive in addition
to being a strong man of knowledge and
science he's had an outstanding
professional career he started out in
the Soviet foreign ministry which of
course most of you know who have some
familiarity with the Soviet Union was
the most professional of the Soviet
bureaucracies they were extremely
skilled exemplary in all respects he was
the ambassador last ambassador to Turkey
of the Soviet Union in fact he was the
last ambassador and point appointed to
any post by Mikhail Gorbachev before the
breakup of the Soviet Union and he
quickly took on the post as ambassador
to Turkey for his new country of
Kazakhstan in the post-soviet period
he's had a number of high posts within
kazakhstan itself
he's been the foreign minister of
kazakhstan in 1994 he will signed the
nato partnership for peace agreement and
also and this is equally important
although not included in his
english-language bio was responsible for
a number of very important agreements
that linked up the economies of the
former Soviet Union and greatly
stabilized the economy of Kazakhstan
through the breakup of those countries
so the formation of the customs union
it's really a remarkable career that
he's had in 2000 I'm skipping ahead
there's quite a lot here he's been
ambassador in a number of foreign
countries in 2000 he was appointed to
the ambassador to the United States and
he served in that post up to the present
day a remarkably long
of tenure in countries that tend to have
a high degree of turnover another
reflection of his remarkable abilities
and I'm sure that he's going to provide
us with some interesting information
today and it's with a great pleasure
that we welcome such a man of high
intellect high culture and high
professional responsibilities to Yale I
hope you all join me in a round of
applause
a hundred Restless stunning natural
beauty deep cultural traditions and
centuries of history third times the
size of Texas Kazakhstan located on the
fabled Silk Road
stretches from the Caspian Sea to China
linking Europe and Asia the history of
the new Kazakhstan started when it
became independent on December 16 1991
in the 15 years since then Kazakhstan
under the remarkable leadership of
President Nursultan Nazarbayev has
turned from one of the worst off
fragments of the fallen Soviet empire
into an economically strong and
dynamically developing democratic
country through successful market and
political leader in Central Asia and a
respected and reliable community today
Kazakhstan exports more than a million
barrels of oil each day as new giant
field holding reserves of more than 100
billion barrels are developed Kazakhstan
will export more than 3 million barrels
daily by 2015 becoming one of the
world's leading exporters today's
Kazakhstan is not only a major oil
industrial and agricultural economy it
has also a country developing new
technologies which has already sent its
first satellite into space
but 15 years ago Kazakhstan future did
not look as bright here at the
Semipalatinsk nuclear test site Moscow
conducted more than 450 nuclear tests
during four decades the tests ruined the
lives of more than one and a half
million innocent people and irradiated
vast areas of once fertile land in
August 1991 president nozzle died of
relying on popular support while defying
threats from the Kremlin made a
courageous decision and shut down the
world's second largest test site at some
people uh tanks by Presidential Decree
after the Soviet Union's collapse
Kazakhstan inherited the world's fourth
largest nuclear arsenal
it included 1,400 nuclear warheads and
was larger than the Arsenal's of Great
Britain France and China combined
despite urgings from so-called
well-wishers from abroad who offered
huge financial incentives in return for
Kazakhstan becoming the first Muslim
nuclear power Kazakhstan voluntarily
renounce its lethal arsenal this bold
move of President Nazarbayev and his
continuing leadership have made an
outstanding contribution to global
nuclear disarmament and
non-proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction in cooperation with the
United States under the nunn-lugar
program Kazakhstan rid itself of all
nuclear weapons and their infrastructure
both the United States Senate and House
of Representatives have called
Kazakhstan's cooperation with the u.s.
in this area a model for such efforts by
other countries
I committed to non-proliferation and
global security and having established
peaceful international relations
insuring favorable conditions for its
economic growth Kazakhstan has proven
that it has gained not lost from
renouncing nuclear weapons and security
to follow us
Kazakhstan is contribution to building a
safer world has not been limited to
nuclear disarmament at the initiative of
President Nazarbayev Kazakhstan created
and continues to host the conference on
interaction and confidence-building
measures in Asia a unique regional
security organization with 18 member
countries representing a total
population of more than 3 billion people
more than half of the world's population
and one-third of the global economy this
grouping brings important contributions
to strengthening peace and stability in
the world the late Pope John Paul the
second called Kazakhstan an example of
harmony between different religions and
nationalities Kazakhstan has convened
congress's of leaders of world and
additional religions creating valuable
forums for reducing tension and
promoting dialogue of civilizations the
development of an independent Kazakhstan
is directly linked to the support of the
United States of America and proud that
for now as president in 1992 the United
States became the first country to
recognize the independence of Kazakhstan
and to establish diplomatic relations
with it the United States supports
Kazakhstan's independence and believes
that its security is vitally important
for stability in Europe and Asia I will
remember the historic occasion in May
1992 when I welcome President Nazarbayev
to the White House the first ever visit
of a head of state from the independent
Kazakhstan the discussions we have that
day have led to a deepening of the
relations between our two countries I
commend President Nasser by for the
progress that Kazakhstan has made in his
short time as an independent country
during their meeting in 2001 President
Nursultan Nazarbayev and George W Bush
announced a strategic partnership
between their two nations since that
time the partnership encompassing
non-proliferation the war on terrorism
energy and building democracy in a
critical region has expanded
significantly Kazakhstan has supported
the United States and Russia in the
Global Initiative to combat nuclear
terrorism Kazakhstan became one of the
very few muslim-majority countries to
send troops to Iraq and remains
committed to its obligations in bringing
peace to that nation Kazakhstan and the
United States worked together to
stabilize Afghanistan as they promote
the vision of a greater Central Asia as
noted by president george w bush quote
the United States views Kazakhstan as a
strategic partner in Central Asia and
values your strong support for our
efforts to bring democracy to Iraq and
Afghanistan
we appreciate the closer cooperation in
combating terrorism and want to expand
this cooperation President Bush also
noted that the stability and prosperity
caused
Don enjoys stand as a model for other
countries in Central Asia and expressed
firm interest in developing cooperation
in ensuring peace stability and
prosperity in this complex region
Kazakhstan and the United States are
strong together the two companies face
new challenges and work for peace and
prosperity in the future this
cooperation will only strengthen the
Kazakhstan looks forward to the future
with optimism believing its commitment
to nuclear disarmament experience with
peaceful coexistence of so many
different nationalities and religions
and peaceful international cooperation
we'll continue to build a safer and more
prosperous world
hey ambassador side of I
my English so through interpreter movie
chefs postman really you well show a
film a castaigne a Tori my years does
one nibble show crystalline a real name
castaigne and Nia tone colors Tanika
Tori new cat Richard with his film
Sasha Barona good afternoon future
American leaders the Ambassador will be
speaking through me you just had a an
opportunity to look at to watch the
short DVD on Kazakhstan which I hope
give you some ideas about what the real
Kazakhstan is about and not the
misconceptions provided in some in the
movie by Sacha Baron Cohen Oh jiminy
domer stated film zero a Brazilian Paulo
Rican Roberto poster if we had the
National Geographic serious kazahstan
Nagaraju Holly whose mighty past the
constellation understand but still
speaking of the movie if we can put this
subject to rest it did provide some
positive benefits for Kazakhstan in that
it made some people willing to learn
about Kazakhstan about the little
country I just caused a stir
Kazakhstan carton mirror by yoshiya
means a visa mega superstars I've seen
you done
she will spit nuts the applause up I'd
like to say that Kazakhstan as an
independent nations as a magnet nation
appeared on the map of the world very
recently only 15 years ago it's not
sleeping as optical Istanbul miss some
may prosper while she say use Mary's
public a resolution which t-mobile Chile
watching Giuliana's let's draw out
brochures obvious casa user
well our chinny chin Oh chin Naga regime
yep as last year
stubborn was a stylist CAC put in the
civilian air in his aviation manga
suffers when Kazakhstan became
independent in December 1991 there were
many reasons for why Kazakhstan would
fail and would not succeed as an
independent nation público para una
ganancia Nana if chaos tiny soaps the
Kazakh
Zastava alle menschen stone a Sylvania
you know the pyramid or idea by Pierre
appreciative you thought the you know
Slava Smallville Buddha the you know
starvation percent of miscellanea
Kazakhstan and una casa hang to begin
with Kazakhstan wasn't a multi-ethnic
country where the ethnic Kazakhs
themselves were in a minority even
though in the census of 1908 a
Kazakhstan the Cossacks were the
Cossacks constituted 98 percent of the
population result-item parsley didn't
acquiesce kizomba
politicking
dota was legit Sark's courtesy post the
river lutetium master would commune
sister communities
remilia soviets was a user and such a an
ethnic diversity became actually the
result of distinctive policies pursued
with a V Kazakhstan by first date
Tsarist Russia and then they come in his
Kremlin
there's no good if Kazakh but what's at
Pier one the word stratum God above Peru
massive Ebola was given treat the room
but after we must have a bullet through
that grass dance cave any corrective
Azad say
paavana Kazakov buggy blue to two times
Kazakhstan was struck by famine in 1921
through 1923 and then in 1929 and 1932
the first instance was caused by the
Civil War and the second was by the
collective as a forced collectivization
and that led to the death or outward
migration of half of ethnic Kazakhs
first approached nvidia kazahstan vs
cassette video called Holocaust
diversity so one can say that last
century Kazakhstan experienced a
holocaust of sorts in its own right
twice mala poaching at Stella economic
astronomy Catherine Pollock El Ninos the
pyramid or cata ratio subbu Galatia
resuits tomb by show a play and a
promotional complex if our teachers
kilos to three percent economic as
Astana
problem is must win the second major
reason for why Kazakhstan should have
failed was the backward nature of the
economy and the presence of many
enterprises of the Soviet military and
industrial complex
basically ninety more than 90 percent of
Kazakhstan's economy were directed and
managed out of Moscow from beyond
Kazakhstan borders territory kazakhstan
naka de la terre the other proprietary
polygon me reports Nevada semi volatile
scale now Catherine teach a nice are
Akali bullies with on a bully pick Assad
Adam here my adorable
for more than 40 years Kazakhstan was
home to the world's second largest
nuclear test site second to the Nevada
Test Site here in the United States
where the Soviet Union conducted almost
500 nuclear tests in the 40 years of its
existence there is a target or upon you
Pastor Adel a bully polluter Emilio
neutral stance if Germany violated and
there again made more than 1.5 million
people in Kazakhstan innocent people in
Kazakhstan suffer fall for no good
reason
yeah bull many was company one year as
Guevara swidnik authority on revolt
early era booty is this a new in the
previous a nooner start of a me
part of the experiment and who then
suffered enormous loss to the health and
lives after the because of the test side
because of the tests occur Kiowas castle
to knock on moon is a vision masuka's
Astana kizomba limine she mentions fetch
him drugged if not Sun dynasty after LOM
Kazakhstani Garagiola if she won't
provide rest of Italy bully standards on
honesty is Erica confusion and as I said
in the beginning the ethnic Kazakhs were
in a minority at the time of
Independence and oak but overall they
were and they still are more than 100
ethnic groups and 40 different religions
represented in Kazakhstan schedule what
now at ammonia will produced at each now
area are Islamorada priests khazzani
prognosis of arsenic darnisha
rizvi gia at least learn astronomy now
this was the background against which
all kind of gloomy and doomy predictions
were made about the future of of such a
complex country Oh
sutures reduced immersed or kazahstan
fact each escaped newsmosis toyota
policy a new service ambassador Stan
Olivo reserve would need not sonic
inflicted Ellis nashit constant envoy
Brazilian meadow
chess for a seotaiji chassis Shoku Tata
and the bottom line of those predictions
were that Kazakhstan would not survive
as a as a state in its own right and it
would be torn apart either by
interesting conflicts or by outside
interference and some of the territory
would Kazakh would be lost to Russia or
some to some other countries just like
you much it prognosis tabouli he
override me I mean you can't ski
expertly and we respected American
experts who were also singing the same
song about the Abu tomska's October with
an ally at kudo Kazakhstan Russia who
knows Billy Petronius Lou Boudreau Boris
Publica Bush was alias Casa user Sam who
is losing a victim named lewdly rez
Vidya it transformed at say we need a
vision manga so Dustin and I told you
all that so that you know where
Kazakhstan is coming from and to tell to
give you the understanding that
Kazakhstan of all other former Soviet
republics had perhaps the most difficult
situation on its hands he what position
you pit not still yet miss Gorda stood
over him stupid with the ischium Salida
stone natural parole presidenta no
tsuita no no survivor Kazakhstan so stay
Elsa years avoid economic machine in a
mystery the Welsh Democritus Kaka
Siddhartha reasonably leader central
energy at Whitney you've arrived partner
Murad no sob sister fifteen years since
that time we are proud to say that under
the outstanding leadership of President
Nursultan Nazarbayev Kazakhstan survived
and became a state in its own right and
became economically strong and
dynamically developing democratic
country a recognized leader in the
region and the reliable partner of the
international community Pasolini voice
alertness economic relates imagine
emizner reservoir economic a mirror my
practice Kira Gooden the youngest
audience percent
for the past eight years Kazakhstan has
been one of the most dynamic economies
in the world and our annual growth
ranges about ten eleven percent annually
for the past nine eight years she would
new nosh neuter novella product sauce
table of de varias appreciated will
appear very strong central energy pic of
casa today Kazakhstan's gross domestic
product is twice as large as the
economies of other countries in Central
Asia and even countries in Caucasus
combined we run ships here in fact even
if reveille arena Schnee preserve an
australian silver coin today reforming
spear way yet similar we introduced the
market reforms market reforms the
fastest of all other countries and we we
have we were done with them maybe five
or seven years after our independence no
previous you moose Mowgli but Lee
Chattanooga bull chakras public service
caused a user
Safran eternally Maginot Sinhalese
[ __ ] mir such surname is not
synonymous a classy but the most
important result is that we were able to
preserve peace and harmony in our very
diverse in multi-ethnic society as
opposed to many many other former Soviet
republics which saw bloodshed based on
those reasons the rosetone with Zulily
the mass of ideally such dirt or no
potential of meeting we post the results
of escs I use Ukraine Belarus Kazakhstan
stylee habla de telling me which in
series not watching seriously I
generally the second contribution
Kazakhstan has made is in renouncing the
world's fourth largest nuclear arsenal
as you know when the Soviet Union
collapsed the nuclear weapons were left
in Kazakhstan Belarus and Ukraine
what litchi no Rossio stole a premium
becomes obvious cause I use stole a
journey year away an oculus it in
Oh crane evil ooh Volusia Tom problem
nibble it William livre Piske he
christiansí strongly found much it
pretty pretty noblest oh yeah only
potentially we do receive and of course
Russia became the legal successor to the
United to the Soviet Union and inherited
the nuclear weapons but as far as
Ukraine and Belarus were concerned they
weren't no major questions about which
way they would go in terms of their
nuclear weapons they were European
nations mostly Christian countries and
there was little question that the
nuclear weapons from them will be
returned to Russia Kazakhstan Ebola so
Pastrana strana spring mooshed muscle
mask in the selenium II Kaname no graft
of Rhema praise Allah
Aras Navarro day Musharraf Kotori lover
le presento to pass 30 a general severe
booty instantly muscle masochist renewal
he had an idea railway was boot over at
over rats when would she taught so with
a media but Kazakhstan was special in
that sense it was an is a predominantly
Muslim nation and in the early days of
our independence we had no short
shortage of foreign emissaries who came
to Kazakhstan and urged the President to
keep the nuclear weapons telling him
that you will be respected in the world
and you will be feared in the world so
you should and you will be the first the
world's first Muslim nation with the
nuclear weapons at that time yes but you
know my charlie consider most pyramid
the most thorough Agoda he after
revision with a Boeing since also oxime
long merchants camara Porto now
Catherine predicted in this Takeshima
serif
universe to a staff Jelena regime with a
convoy in polling every dollar of
provision series in wash economies key
problem and I am reminded always of the
first time I saw a Boeing 747 in my life
and I was in the Almaty
Airport
at the end of 1991 early 1992 when one
of those emissaries arrived on such a
plane and his argument was if you keep
the weapons you get this point load of
dollars which will help solve all of
your problems with keeping the weapons
the other strategies Rises corsage to
publish abortions to a little pallet is
crediting the Wolverine if kazahstan
to dribble as a tour stop when we
establish yeah Ana Lucia Lucia BIA p.m.
salmon moon even
munagi Vika Oscar balloon kazahstan
Padma Chelsea Stan I will say I turn in
your away boo-boos no way over on me to
be fair the majority of the elite in
Kazakhstan at that time was also were
also in favor of keeping the nuclear
weapons which they saw as the
opportunity to take revenge for all
those centuries and decades of
repressions and persecutions and which
they saw as an opportunity to become a
nuclear power
overnight and they recognized can't a
respected and fearful country on the
international arena is easier choice
casado
well show a modest way mudras privilege
'no president astronauts another wife
Kotori parent of rimia practices kim
liech neurasthenia it would be deal with
them now root at Quezada that I
generally he passed did me what if it
not yet natural as VTA parkas are stable
it is the prime mover so and on this
note I should say that it is the wisdom
and the courage of our president nor
sought another wife that made it
possible for him to make this choice the
non-nuclear choice and he was able to
convince the elites and the people that
it is a right choice to renounce nuclear
weapons and the 15 years since then
have only proven the that this choice
was a correct one yeah do my steaming
water truck nazar by Pradeep readily
naxi at machine you said youngish tata
me Kotori would say a tip it nuts at
Liat parties cannot Jeffress know Lea
she would new harakiri zooids a cap
strategies k partner strong and I
believe that it is this decision by
prisoners above which set the tone for
the relations between Kazakhstan and the
United States which have begun from
scratch and now have grown into a
relationship of strategic partnership it
is treated real strategies partners this
region Kazakhstan is - I see what new
coaching - you're the say you sneaky in
a gorge new partnering new brush Lee
will show plotted warning puts a true
news from nagas fear a Porteous kazow
feeling I've especially laburnum is a
past mistake pretty vast a anneristo
strongly new Adair novorossiya Pineiro
erh is cast aside noonish that america's
animal origins in deposits rather Bhatia
in richest resource of kazakhstan
kazakhstan a fatuous collage table died
after image media the person who live at
the road no Serie A blood I treat you
nearer over
Purana a vacuum atom which has - it was
robot key which a suit American ski
company and I'd like to say that this
relations is indeed one of tragic
partnership the countries our two
countries are firm allies and partners
in many issues first as I described is
was our cooperation first and foremost
was our cooperation in ensuring global
security and dismantling Kazakhstan's
nuclear arsenal together
secondly we are jointly standing against
the proliferation of such weapons in the
world and cooperating actively still to
this day
thirdly the United States is a
major investor in Kazakhstan and it is
US companies present in Kazakhstan very
solidly Kazakhstan is estimated to hold
the world's second largest oil reserve
by different accounts and Kazakhstan has
the one third of the world's uranium
reserves and in all those areas we have
the very strong cooperation going on
with the United States and US government
and private businesses are involved all
Cheney was not just side you on the
start of Donna Blaney kazahstan akak
Democratic Attorney spearonation is
officially mr. about a man with a sphere
she would new res vidya liberal desert
circle stands co-op schifflet Tajima its
leader ischium national union here on
schedule miniature practice kiss newly
as she would email him real news
officials for both know pretty soon as
castaigne bought bullied voltage 3's
massive inform at see his new beau
levesque miss PG % of at just miss me
insufficient miss me rebooted bully pttc
new provost organization national as
much it at ecology skew sequential a
pacifist email another party no sister
Marianna gist which Adina's party
scattered theorists on the Parliament a
noble school Kojima grata at ETL cut
Rosa khutor not of cygnus limits in
previous elections tenuto Labrador I'm
rebooted coordination of Lublin
democratic school reform era nauseous
[ __ ] what book one the Terra Australis
- Edina gastrostomy she for Democritus
'it's a porsche stupid progestin
presidenta nauseous [ __ ] player button
take initiative to change what the
recommended say she would new period of
study results Susan Bucher group policy
new is many new constitutes and a
problem not an issue the more democratic
scale reformer in kurdistan of course
one of the most important areas of our
relationship since the very beginning
has been building democracy in
Kazakhstan and the United States is a
very strong partner in that area and we
have engaged in a very vigorous dialogue
and cooperation on that score as well
and the results are there to see as well
Kazakhstan leads the way in the region
in terms of reforms we have now more
than 2000 independent news media outlets
whereas 15 years ago there was almost
none we have 5000 nongovernmental
organizations dealing with all the
issues so you can imagine one can
imagine from the environment protection
to the to peacekeeping and promoting
peace and peaceful resolution of
conflicts we have 11 political parties
in the country of which 4 have seats in
the national parliament and of course
democracy is an ideal to which one has
to continuously strive for and struggle
for and we intend to continue democratic
reforms in Kazakhstan we understand we
have some ways to go
just yesterday the special state
commission on democratization had a
session in Kazakhstan where the
president outlined the new plans for the
for democratic reforms based on the
results of that Commission's work during
the past year so now those
recommendations including ones that will
require changes into the Constitution
which now they are going in
the stage of implementation and a
special working group was established to
put them to prepare those changes into
the Constitution and offer them to the
people she would new expert in palatal
again as an amaru she's an awesome
original Salem if justice kazahstan go
variate Icaza stands computer sweetie
you have ideals cuz I'd once to data
kazahstan skip with res vidya today
experts in political science a lot of
majors internationally talk of
Kazakhstan and talk of Kazakhstan's way
of development and I can I would like to
spend a minute at which explaining what
they mean by this night should kazahstan
spirit abridging use a visa master
recipe well I p.rajesh me temple me deal
economics California very formidable
buzzes yeah but ax Gaza since the first
days of in the profits independence
Kazakhstan has pursued economic and
market reforms much more strongly and
vigorously than political reforms the
way to reform a path leader within the
party really politically billiards
Orchestra but those economic reforms
were continuously and consistently
supported and followed by those
political reforms but a monster pirate
Lambie will be chairing the premier
reform service console using the garbage
of I believe a palliative liberalism
Orchestra solution is a Brazil economy
ko
IRA's reef what Mears the score is
dynamic will be no politics care reform
is estoy in the economic a pre you'll
collapse really pay around and we
pursued those policies for for a reason
we had a very powerful example in the
Soviet Union which collapsed because
Gorbachev
pursued very actively live political
liberalisation while neglecting and
failing to do anything about economic
reforms and it was this discrepancy
between the speed and the depths of
political liberalization in the Soviet
Union and the stagnation in the economy
which tore apart the Soviet Union
petomane Wesley what Amon what our
agenda sabbatical put in ERG is named
Cardinal economics California past
leader within past epyon but crippling
Democritus came early for me so that's
why we chose that path we followed
pursuing energetic vigorous economic
reforms followed by political reforms
EMU sleep sure it would evolution
important movie diem stone territory
boost as a user
no we need a visa mega Siddhartha
reservoirs bathroom no problem at the
porn industry porn estefania Pollock and
Lavazza Paris VT of Chester and we have
continuously pursued those policies
along the evolutionary type of
development we are seen that in the
former Soviet Union the new independent
states have developed alone two
different ways a means a complete lack
of reforms a complete lack of change and
complete stagnation and preservation of
what ever existed there before steroid
at nicest whose Carini east coast north
korean uniform capita prices low Rosie
in Ukraine and B is forceful and sort of
artificial artificial jump starting on
the reforms which we also in Georgia and
Ukraine through those revolutions cut
Picasa with what we talk your as Vidya
post er enjoy a higher value today Kelly
easier registry of Tirana editors
new watching was fiercely put its custom
parts to give it you know brush a
pneumonia na addictiveness Australia
annual turkey process and of course
there was another revolution in
Kyrgyzstan but as we see now the results
of those revolutions they are not
particularly encouraging and they again
have failed to resolve the fundamental
issues in the societies and they were
there again they were made without the
resolution of those underlying economic
problems mostly Tamiya to me about he's
a change water tava booty to change the
practice of res vision is a vision
castle ours
thud mr. aney would partners of i'ma
kazahstan skip which occur to me as
kazow he rotated wah
drew give fuji res VT mineral VT know
he's a business person at the ocean
interest me perspective made him what
was more than a wash of knowledge the
program the ammonia tap Panama's dough
Ian etter
real name the solution cogency
American scape leader of the other most
audit process yes the wizard channel is
a system in Volusia normally liberal
perspective bring you might watch improv
it was tradition at NASA Tina thank you
process of resolution strand so you will
see the three different ways of
development in the former Soviet Union
one way of almost no development the
forceful speeding up of those reforms
revolutions
they Kasich the evolutionary way of
development and I believe it may be an
interesting subject force scholarly
research at Yale especially since this
is the laboratory of future leaders of
the United States and it will be helpful
if such a research conducted and the
leaders of this country have a better
grasp of the intricacies and processes
of development of other countries if the
rule was pure Kazakhstan aversion new
toolkit Lakers Astana inversion is
rebellion to us cassava vishnupuri
ischemia
Kotori State Police a new statement at
the provision support democratic media
was purchased Anna Donna Gladney premier
to democracy
it was personal initially Anamika some
misty me it was morning in muscle man's
quest Rani Couture effective skillet
Kurdistan and another important reason
for why it deserves more research is
that Kazakhstan success is not just
success of Kazakhstan it is also
important for the United States as it
pursues what I can call the sort of
eternal agenda of promoting freedom and
democracy in the world and its historic
mission and Kazakhstan's Kazakhstan is
an example that democracy and market
successful market can coexist in a
Muslim society in a Muslim country which
is which is what Kazakhstan is we would
repeatedly th was Kazakh mrs. Dolly
fundament
use a vision of a Siddhartha know period
Nami Kharkov Salem PD they do not stay
at watching slowly with the way negatory
monotony Nike dystonia t we believe that
in those 15 years of our independence we
just laid the foundation for our future
development but we still face major
challenges both domestically and in
region ratio is not a widow of data
usable 8 valence cable is new new state
sir even pre dot-com plasma Turkish
odors on the domestic front the biggest
challenge is to avoid the so-called
Dutch disease and to prevent Kazakhstan
from becoming a raw materials appendix
or annex to developed nations Islam we
know Jim DeYoung that's doing that via
Twitter and thank God we are finding
answers to those and ways to answer
those challenges 3 wouldn't know that
who knows below Pranita strategies
program in the Matteson industry on
numerous video
Kotori aah - snarls ooh say that a
program with difficile diffusivities of
marsh economy co a witty at as a visa
master at me nifty gaza septa and we
recognize this challenge and we have
pursued measures to tackle this
challenge three years ago we we started
implementing an ambitious strategy of
industrial and innovation innovative
development whose goal is to diversify
Kazakhstan's economy away from the
dependence on oil and gas reserve a
mattress numerous even transport
communicates a merese viability
ethnology with a graduate adam energetic
oh you know what eventually drama crania
brazil mind and we are developing those
different industries such as
transportation and communications bio
technologies we will be developing
peaceful atomic energy and we are
spending considerable amounts on
developing health care and education
recipient 80 bodies Israeli posture
plane if Canadian budget which it is
rich this thank you
sorry
Experion variate of a buddha near dean
dollar is a lot about managing avoid
Puget Meridian business to gain
experience of God and you know couply to
nots an unoffending
Kotori million demolish Poquelin for
several years we have continuously
removed the oil revenues we were
receiving from our oil and gas
industries into and put them away into a
national fund of future generations and
as of January 1st this year we are
living completely without dependence on
those oil money which in their entirety
are diverted to this national fund for
future generations in useful Jeremy
she's just bringing a new program of
Virginia Kazakhstan leadership would be
a slow night ball you can Korean
Pospisil Nostrand Mira is not a terrible
team you it then came as no coincidence
that Kazakhstan unveiled a program to
become one of the world's 50 most
competitive nations we are working hard
and to achieve that goal now his new
Yahoo is the Vatican yashna all roses
lanskaya Eastern isness yoga with no
limit until Azad Nostra non-clinician
south when Astana narco traffic
Ettore Bravo teams percent of narcotic
of a rock opera which is Costanza
ringing Judith - tanta G castanos
biggest on Kazakhstan - Laura C which is
a civil of the external challenges I
would mention first the threat of
Islamic extremism Islamist extremism in
Central Asia as you know we are not far
from Afghanistan we have only one
country between us and Afghanistan and
also the drug trafficking coming out of
Afghanistan more than 70% of
opium and heroin coming out of
Afghanistan going to Europe passes
through Kazakhstan so Tajikistan
Uzbekistan then Kazakhstan then through
Russia then on to Europe you can usually
my producer I'm done should miss a new
study me are about the Syrian airspace
training courtesy would near Ocean
Australia need I booked a seat a key
element to Papa DeLuca terrorists and of
course we are continuing to work closely
with the United States and others to
prevent the proliferation of weapons of
mass destruction and their components
god forbid such weapons all components
found a way found their way into the
hands of terrorists poeta mo na xie
shaggy posea traduced sub with audience
toys in tabria tata shapiro of would
condemn president i build a tongues
Tokido Stan this was flown budget period
side noonish that America will body be
explored in terrorism he does not show
chest evil - Tanya she would just go in
scope contingent is Kazakhstan that
instantly contingent is Narayana prodigy
when Thomas tawantza rhaenyra's mini
Ravana balaji 300 million of their own
Nicastro a Tinashe it's just a name he
built in the Iranian and coming from
those understandings Kazakhstan took the
steps immediately after the tragic
events of 9/11 to support the United
States in the war on terrorism our
president came out with a statement
right away pledging the unconditional
support for the United States we have
seen stood by these commitments
providing support on Afghanistan and
then becoming the only country in
Central Asia and one of the very few
Muslim majority countries to send troops
to Iraq we still have troops in Iraq
our contingent however small continues
to serve with distinction they have
destroyed more than four million pieces
of deadly ordnance there and we are
committed to keeping them there as long
as it is needed and those decisions to
support the u.s. in the Warren Chisum
and to send troops to Afghanistan were
our natural and objective decisions
based on our convictions I choose Kadesh
from diminishing as Astana pastor Ulla
Maija broccolini oka Toria Bush Lisa
gets cosas using most conditioner the
cars didn't see the alpha-male cars
didn't she grab Nam learning is drawing
a new instrument but Olivia's natural
parent president what I would like to
also say is that the foundation for
Kazakhstan's independence which we have
now laid was basically laid by my
generation by the people who have come
out from the Soviet Union who have had
to struggle daily to share their old
habits to change their ways and to adopt
new life
iota mu C would new guamazo Daksha
national park Alenia a stylet period I'd
seen in his division because of Stan
when I gorge near okay yo Buddha she
okay
so that is why our goal today is to pass
along the the country as we have it to a
younger generation which will be
harmonious with China what fully digital
yet Kazakhstan news to it program
bullish are sir glass negatory poor
president they should go so does not
relate he would Volusia which evenings a
Virginia mera Russia melodically
so there is why we have the presidential
bola shock which means the future
scholarship program
under which kazakhstan sends its best
and brightest to the best universities
in the world for studies all expenses
paid
yes they don't know how good the
topology goodness totally Mia cast in
Sherwood when a problem traditionally
Akasha
up until last year we were sending about
a hundred students abroad annually but
as of last year we are sending 3,000
students a chance America who's a cattle
Annie at Georgetown with a garment with
a Columbia University of Massachusetts
acknowledges canoes yet new Catherine
washing machine sequentially
I knew the animal was new positive
positive economic business astronomy the
majority of those students go to the
United States
and they go to Georgetown or George
Washington Harvard MIT and to Yale and
coming back they are assuming leadership
positions in both the government and in
the private sector the moonsto Learner's
was the new toolkit or tiny pocket cup
with a minimally margins money in
formats a speech science professional
version toast oh I knew PETA would she
be a principal Democrats are inca stone
otherwise the public charity at their
waist which Niko hotness Italy uni
produce the cars the rosboroughs a
subway
what is especially important about those
youngsters is that they don't just get
the best education there is from the
best professors there are but they are
getting steeped in the traditions of
democracy and in the principles of
market economy and they get in them
directly from the people who have grown
up with them and that is the important
thing that they bring those back to
Kazakhstan and they don't have to win
themselves away from the old habits of
this so
Union mr. Noles organics catch SEO Mira
ozone or Buddha sugar and as they become
and assume those positions they become a
an important link between Kazakhstan and
the international community
hey Tommy I see beardless abashed I'll
show a privilege Eva so Cochise to see
what he was to fight Russian the machete
named after idiot and wash I'm on
achievements I didn't
Kotori emulates a prison kuznia say a
leader of Saia under start of america
new you see richness name as pep oh yeah
bro shall ye written in gravity Russia
will push new prezi a sort of 13
presidents George Ubu sure he would
chase yet Bravo Team see what mr. Rossi
so that's why I feel especially honored
and privileged to be able to address you
today at Yale and one of the world's
most respected and associative
universities and I have a personal story
to tell as well I presented my
credentials as the ambassador for come
from Kazakhstan six years ago last week
to a Yalie to Bush President Bush George
W Bush and since that time we have been
working very well together in the period
nurse to what student ivara università
but I really
Saku allegiance the interiors in sativa
publisher was not open yet my astronomy
Italia tahajud Putnam me a total
copperheads to him and I'm especially
pleased and excited to hear the about
the initiative of the students from your
University who would organize the summer
in Kazakhstan program this summer we we
can only welcome this issue would
newness below haroche f stretches with
president fashionista co-star Amy
Poehler whiskers on a stage near jelenia
which Calista Kazakhstan's Abu shape
severe
Tsutomu co-worker washing donut morning
will be acquired and today I had a
meeting with Vice President Lyndon
Lorimer who also expressed the interest
in seeing more Catholic students come
over here and she even reprimanded us
for heaven-sent and too much on
Washington area universities and saying
we should go out more into the country
whether she was public under it which is
awash it Albania stolen away specially
phasmid really acceptable showing a
video film immersion bedroom kazahstan
start retreat panettone Church religion
and I'd like to thank you for your
patience for your time and that you has
have given me I was so thankful that you
had the opportunity to watch this to to
watch this DVD and I hopeful and I'm
hopeful that in the end Kazakhstan
became a better understood place for you
at the end my own accrued captious
Russia mr. gentle me assure us Sylvia
Nash tobu - American Idol haka and my
rather short in two courses while rather
communications and conversations with
your students have again proven to me
that the United States is in good hands
and will be in good hands
spasibo one will spare thank you and
good luck
yes we are approaching up around a lot
of applicants if you have any questions
I would be happy to answer them
no Tolkien Ybarra but anything not
related to Bharat darkness perhaps in
English is better for everybody was my
integrity
ev3 swoosh new media
Virginia trend the US Open and really
was known restaurants to approach Tarun
Anushka bode poorly and I should say we
debated Nepali are now in we is formally
really wash my sheets so two questions
the first one is about the sort of value
integration in the sort of global world
and particularly in the religious
integration or religion and the position
of Kazakhstan not only geographical
position bellows or multicultural
position what are the trends and where
do we see this value conversion and the
second question about the today's
discussion on the unipolar unipolar
world versus other model
conversation those are the two questions
yeah demoted via tonight approach and
Carly at Whitmore at the election well I
think the answers to those questions
married a lecture every one of them in
its own right
when we pasteurize about courage Inka
Peru applause marina Hodgins when you
can the apologies compilers in you match
it cracks collagen mudra Israeli
politics cars they would stamp
recipients Gaza Stein said in class on
video
ruskov Nvidia terrorism Keith
ice-covered Rock Cunha
but I wouldn't publish because of
stamina yes Gaza but I would like to be
short and provide the short answers
Kazakhstan is indeed in a very unique
Geographic and geopolitical position as
one wise Israeli politician told us
Kazakhstan is in a situation where it
has to wake up every morning having one
eye fixed on the Russian bear to the
north and another one fixed on the
Chinese dragon to the east and I talked
already about the thousand neighbors of
Kazakhstan and the challenges we face
from their religious casa no
Confucianist Rana
he has no national blockapalooza at a
near evaluation and see religion but as
far as popper in skin opacity of
Kazakhstan bhootish pyramid ooh nas well
a toast renew premium Garr Mooney means
the machine is range enemy I studied
numerous lives nationally serie de
janice watch a moussaka uncommon
gardenia even chakra net the Crimea as
far as the religious integration and
religious values in the world are
concerned we as I said Kazakhstan is a
multi-ethnic country we have made a
specific effort to preserve this piece a
mandrill ethnicities and religions we
were
obviously thrilled and pleased by the
words of the late pope john paul ii when
he visited kazakhstan you know 2001
calling us an example of harmony between
men and women of different origins and
beliefs so we intend to pursue the same
policies to promote tolerance and
understanding stoke asides nepali arles
Anakapalli our nation is near Mira
I thought proscar that Wichita swim cars
DeVito Stone quest via Twitter near as
far as the debates about the unipolar or
multipolar world today I think everybody
every single person will have his own
ideas about this and everybody sees what
he or she wants to see just please
hi could you talk a little bit about the
relationship between Kazakhstan and
Russia and whether that relationship is
weakened by the fact that you're
allowing yourself more with Western
powers and with the notion of democracy
and Western ideas Thanks absolutely at
national champs to Kazakhstan kakuka
where each year she will show us a
serious supper than we assumed she bears
up Adam the bullet about predict a
democratic it's a nasty yahoo mail cars
the strana swim race VT proceed with
drill she was very soaps name not
synonymous
I believe that review robotium residence
with the worst of Hamilton
I believe that every country as it
develops pursues its own national
national interests first of all and it
develops with with a view towards
ensuring those and interests and not in
order to be liked by some other country
ricean our village associate a partner
we see a average generic nesting sati
strongly in with the interior oven but I
see Sydney if Anastasia Democratic
escape
Russia is our great neighbor and partner
we are destined to live together with
Russia and we are interested in seeing a
strong Russia and a democratic Russia
yeah the more I see the interior zone of
the country Kazakhstan and I believe
that Russia is looking to Kazakhstan to
develop along the same lines please
what specific targets you have towards
reaching your Democratic goals priest a
terrible touch strangest anemic people
can create not politically say leave it
so - we simple strategy with a mud
machine your hotels Gaza Syria
unbuttoned Nam cm is a new new star Tom
Tom cheese nearest a tissue robotics
Polynesia more food chain new solutions
in democratic process
I hate ammonia patios Kadesh though
Democritus at CES natural and when
you're concerned well I actually wanted
to put it in a broader sense and saying
that and say that it's not just
Kazakhstan but even the United States
has ways to go in improving its
democratic processes as I believe there
is the start and the beginning of the
process of building a democracy but
there is no end the other motivation so
I think it's an eternal movement for us
cognitive scale to democratic posturing
that national table Rodney process in
the moment we are complacent we say okay
we now have built a complete democracy
that's when the recession and the
regression regress starts firstly show
us
spasibo and I'll show ya yeah pushing
one blogger darling I see what you see
Richmond so again thank you very much
I'm very your attention I'm hopeful that
we will have many more occasions to come
together and